this is a production of Cornell
University
and thank you all for coming I'm really
excited to talk about this today uh so
my title of soul and agriculture from
competition to co-location so I'm really
going to be trying to focus on ways that
we can build Bridges between some of
these different land uses
uh just a little bit about the structure
of this talk I'm going to start with a
section that's kind of just a big
picture about solar inciting uh what's
our outlook for solar what kind of uh
challenges do we expect to face in land
use for solar and how do um what I'll
broadly call Innovative citing Solutions
uh fit into that challenge
then I'm going to really focus in on
agual picks the practice of combining
solar and agriculture together I'll talk
about sort of what those Technologies
look like why we think they're
interesting and what some benefits might
be
um
then I'm going to talk a little bit
about our research portfolio at the
department of energy that specifically
focuses on solar energy culture so
um you know one thing I'll get into a
little bit is I I come from an applied
research office so we're really focused
on enabling and pushing Technologies
forward more than we are on the
regulatory side
all right so let's let's talk about
solar and sort of solar from a strategic
perspective
um the story of solar in the last 10
years that is is kind of really
important to wrap your head around is
rapidly falling costs and rapidly Rising
deployment
um so some of this is obviously due to
policy pushes in terms of climate goals
like New Yorks or others but some of
this is all but I really want to
emphasize the degree to which the cost
of solar which is here it's the right
access here and the line graph
um you can see that the cost of solar in
a per kilowatt hour basis fell from
nearly 30 cents a kilowatt hour in 2010
to down near five cents kilowatt hour in
2020. I'm not sure if we have 20 21
numbers out and finalized yet but that's
been accompanied with really rapid
growth in the sector so in 2010 you can
see here this is in gigawatts of
capacity you're seeing I don't know one
or two and
uh that's ramped up in 2021 the
projection was that we would install 20
about 120 watts of utility scale solar
so that's the story of the the sort of
2010s in solar and is really remarkable
just in terms of how different the
economics are
um from what we were talking about and
this really is due to scale up and
Manufacturing as well as as well as
favorable policy environments
uh the result of this is that now when
we look at 2021 solar is
um the most
common new source of generating capacity
so when you look at what was added this
is from the from the under information
agency look at what was added Nationwide
uh nearly over 15 gigawatts of solar
were added that outstrips wind natural
gas batteries nuclear and other
um
and so as a result you can see that uh
solar is becoming rapidly one of the
largest growing sectors of the energy
industry and and really starting to to
take on a much more prominent role
the problem to this role we really
explored in a report that we published
last September called the solar future
state so solar future study is this
report that my office created in
partnership with the National
Laboratories that really started trying
to chart a pathway to providing large
amounts of U.S electricity through solar
by 2050. so we're currently at about
three percent of the electricity in the
US comes from solar energy this starts a
pathway to 45 and it looks at basically
decarbonization Pathways achieving 95
decarbonation by 2035.
um
so this is not one where solar is the
sole energy source I don't think anyone
is is really aiming for that but one
where solar is is in some ways maybe the
dominant energy source so in these
scenarios there's there's a couple of
them there's the reference scenario
um there's a decarbonization scenario
where we we sort of work very hard to
decarbonize the power system in which
um more and then there's D Card plus e
in which we not only try to cover as the
power system but we also focus on
electrifying loads so converting
vehicles to EVS converting heating from
natural gas to electric heat pumps or
things like that and so in these
scenarios you see that we go from 80
gigawatts uh in 2020 to a terawatt
potentially in 2035 maybe a terawatt and
a half by 2050. there's a lot more Solar
Development coming
and I also want to emphasize it really
comes to new places so if you look at it
um
in the early 2010s or mid-2010s maybe
the the major capacity was deployed in
like California Nevada Arizona these big
sunny places lots of deserts
um and we're really seeing already
that's starting to change I think
California is no longer the largest
state for solar capacity appointments I
believe it's Texas now but you also see
Florida Georgia the southeast really
coming up and in the long term in these
high Solar Development scenarios we're
seeing more solar deployed in these
census regions that currently don't have
very much
um
such as the Northeast and Midwest so
these places that now don't have very
much will have more solar in the future
than you know California for instance
does today
and that brings us to the land of the
land challenge so solar land use you
know I don't want to oversimplify it
it's really varies a lot based on panel
efficiency how the plant is laid out the
latitude you're at you know further
south there's more sun
um my rule of thumb is you know five
acres a megawatt basically so we're
talking you know we're talking about a
terawatt that's a billion Watts so we're
talking about you know millions of Acres
[Music]
um
so when we look into what we're looking
at in these scenarios we're really
seeing land use increasing to 2035 to up
to about 5.7 million acres to as much as
10 million Acres Nationwide in 2050.
that would be about 0.5 percent of the
U.S land area which would be larger than
the state of Maryland as you can see
from this graph
so I want to um
kind of this is the tension that we sort
of live in I think when in the Solar
land use discussion 0.5 percent of U.S
land area you know it pales in
comparison to some other land uses such
as the amount of urban area and paved
roadways we already have even the amount
of previously disturbed land is much
larger than that there's also a very
sizable chunk of this that you know
maybe not all of it would be like
contaminated land or brown fields or
things like that so you know compared to
the total land available in the U.S
maybe it doesn't look that large but 10
million acres is still obviously quite a
bit of land and it's not going to be
evenly distributed right there are
certain places that are closer to
transmission lines get have better
climates or flat or whatever that are
going to experience this more than
others and that's going to lead to some
local friction
some friction to be is to be expected
um and I think that that is maybe a
little bit of a soft pedaling of it
we're really starting to see this as a
major concern for the industry
um as there's various local concerns and
increasingly organized local opposition
to some of these projects so some of it
um is really about preservation Prime
farmland or Pine Forest land some of it
is about concerns over Health impacts
and these are all you know tied up very
deeply with what an individual
community's feels as its identity as
well as kind of where the local economy
is at and also
um
you know what other land use changes are
kind of causing uh concerns and these
are also very deeply bound up I will say
in what the individual communities
zoning and land use policies are like
which vary greatly from place to place
and state to state obviously in how they
are structured
so you know there's lots of ways forward
on this I think I I don't want to as I
said we don't want to frame land use as
an absolute constraint there is enough
land to accomplish this energy
transition and so most of the solution
will probably still use traditional
solar siding on Green Fields I mean uh
we need to get better at things like
learning how to facilitate regional and
local land use planning to minimize that
conflict to structure projects so they
provide benefits for communities they're
not just seen as some developer coming
in and doing whatever they want with it
without concern for the Neighbors uh we
need to build things like mapping and
screening tools that can be used to
identify good sites early on and really
provide clearing guidance both to the
developer side and the community side to
help everyone understand the trade-offs
and negotiate through this this
development process
um but one thing that's also really
interesting I think or this broad
category solutions that we call
Innovative citing Solutions
these are ways to cite soil energy that
you cites kind of other than Greenfield
development so the idea is that these
developments will take pressure off of
undisturbed land and kind of expand the
space of where siding can go and open up
new possibilities for communities and
some of these may even have some unique
benefits that go beyond just electricity
so some of the ones that uh you know we
might hear about are things like
brownfields so this is the construction
of solar on former industrial sites or
former
um
uh mine lands for instance
floating solar is increasingly popular I
would say so in this case solar's put on
some kind of pontoons and there's a lot
of interest using this for instance on
hydropower reservoirs uh on canals or
things like that
um
this is a picture of mine Land
Development again doex has a very large
program for demonstrating renewable
energy on former mine land that came out
in the infrastructure package that's not
what I'm going to be talking about today
but I I'm also very involved in that and
then Canal solar as well is something
that's being tried in California I think
one of the interesting things about some
of these water-based Solar Solutions is
they can also avoid evaporation and
potentially result in some water savings
but the one I'm going to be focusing on
today is agricults so aggravatex is
um I will text is the combination of
crop and livestock production or
pollinator habitat underneath solar
panels and or in adjacent zones around
solar panels egg roll text is kind of a
recent term and I'm not sure the field
has really stabilized on calling it that
uh you'll also see it called things like
co-location of solar and agriculture
dual use of solar AG PV
um you know I feel like every time we
run some kind of solicitation on this
everyone who proposes a project needs
something different
and
you know the key idea here is that yes
we're going to have some trade-offs but
the hope is that we can make those
trade-offs sort of work so you know
you're gonna have less light and you're
gonna have more difficulty farming
you're gonna have to kind of navigate
these panels that probably means you're
gonna get less props or less
Agricultural Product or whatever kind
um that might not use it universally be
true but I think that's a that's a fair
assumption to make
simultaneously you're also going to have
to space the panels out or make them
semi-transparent or something like that
to let some light through it or let um
Farm Workers in underneath them and that
might lead to less electricity
production the hope is that if we can do
both of these things then we can win at
kind of the system level so this is a
this is a um
diagram I stole from fraunhofer in
Germany you see on the left they're
saying okay you can imagine having two
hectares where one is all wheat and one
is all solar power
that's all well and good you know maybe
you combine them you're getting 80 of
each but you're doing it on half the
land and so it's 160
um efficiency in comparison and so this
this kind of question of can we address
can we build solar or plus agriculture
with this kind of favorable land
equivalent ratio is really really
important from an economic point of view
um to minimize the land impact of solar
energy and of increasing this
compatibility
so I'm going to walk through now some of
the major modalities we see for
um solar and fault uh solar plus
agriculture so one is pollinators
pollinators are I would say one of the
more advanced versions of this in the
sense that many states are are
um really pushing this in on the policy
level so you know the traditional solar
plant or the sort of most standard one
might plant turf grass or some kind of
easily mowed and managed grass system
many people are now pointing to the
possibility to use solar Fields as a
source of habitat for pollinators such
as birds and bees it's estimated about
23 percent of U.S crops depend on
animals for pollination
it's also further estimated that there's
about 3 500 square kilometers of
agricultural land that's near current or
planned solar developments that could
benefit from this pollinator habitat so
the idea here is that by planting these
um more robust kind of ecosystems around
the solar panels you provide ecosystem
services to nearby land you also have
some other possible benefits for
instance
um there's some studies that we're
starting to see that show that this may
help with water runoff management
because you have deeper rooted plants
that can help with infiltration
uh there are downsides however you know
that the solar developer will now have
to establish this habitat that means
buying special seed mixes that means you
know sort of maintaining it for a few
years especially as it gets established
um and there's a lot of concerns about
um finding a mix of seeds that works
with
um solar in particular that doesn't get
too tall right I mean if you start
shading these panels you see production
drop quite a bit
um so this is something as I said we're
seeing some State policy moves on this
eight states have created pollinator
scorecards to encourage solar facilities
to adopt these kinds of practices
grazing is another really exciting one I
think that is also starting to already
see some commercial purchase so if you
have an animal that grazes you can do it
at solar Farms
one thing that's really interesting is
that grazing is not just a matter of of
saying well we're going to use this land
for something else it actually serves a
purpose to the solar operator which is
that usually you have to mow these
things regularly to make sure that the
vegetation isn't you know swallowing up
your solar panels and there's potential
to use grazing to supplement or replace
that mowing in some cases the
um the cost can be lower that's really
site dependent and there's evidence that
this increases that grazelands have
increased soil carbon and some other
positive impacts on kind of the
grassland ecosystem as well
so as I said we're already seeing
actually a fair amount of commercial
practice for this I believe actually
especially in New York state
um the dominant commercial practice for
this is she so lots of people are
interested in cattle because there's
more cattle than sheep raised in the
United States but these larger animals
they raise a lot more concerns about
panel damage so the idea here is that
the animals get
um
get a chance to raise this they get
forage they also get for instance shade
um
that could be a really important uh
climate adaptation technique potentially
and Farmers actually get a new Revenue
Stream So these the the business model
we're seeing emerge for this is one
where grazers are going to solar sites
having their herds graze and getting
paid for that service which is a really
interesting flip from leasing Pastor
land to actually being paid to go Grace
so finally the third category I'm going
to talk about is crops so crops is
obviously I think maybe even what comes
to mind the most when people think about
agrovaltaics or agriculture around solar
panels
um it's a lot harder I think than the
pollinators are grazing and therefore
it's a little bit less I would say
commercially Advanced although we're
starting to see installations kind of at
the megawatt scale are smaller
um so with cross hackable text we're
talking about growing crops that could
satisfy food fiber or bioenergy needs
really looking beneath or around panels
This unlocks potentially a very large
amount of land and there's evidence that
the shading can provide some drought
resistance and potentially save water
there's some really interesting work out
of Greg Baron gafford's group in Arizona
that's that's really looking at how
these shading affects growth in well
Arizona
um and there's potentially significant
impacts on water use efficiency and
things like that there's also some
potentially some back action on the
panels the transpiration from plants can
cool panels leading to doing a better
micro climate directly beneath them and
that cooling actually improves the
efficiency of solar panels
there's a lot of challenges to crop air
well ticks and I think that it's worth
really discussing what these are because
this is such a an interesting area to
people but it really is one that's still
it begins infancy so some of the
challenge that we're looking at trying
to solve are one and this is kind of
obvious but it's worth saying is plants
need like to grow so pretty much any
agar will take solution you hear about
is trying to figure out a way around the
question of splitting up the sun between
electricity production and plant
production
um
one way is just use shade tolerant crops
many crops do not necessarily need all
of the light that they would get in a
given day and
so there might be ways to uh so there
are usually ways to to adapt to this but
you know we see people trying to use
things like semi-transparent panels
which may or may not be wavelength
selective so I've so some people are
trying to work on panels that
specifically filter out only wavelengths
of light that plants cannot use in
photosynthesis
um for the most part we're also just
seeing spacing the panels out so you see
this this installation here on top is I
believe at the University of
Massachusetts
and this is installation where they're
growing oh sorry I think it's uh
kale or broccoli and these panels are
simply at a larger space in so you're
getting less power per acre out of this
site but you know you're allowing the
plants to capture more that light
uh finally tracking so this refers to
the tracking for solar panels means
whether or not they actually move with
the sun and follow the Sun but many
solar panels track and that can be used
to sort of shift in the shade and
perhaps allow light in at certain times
if there are certain times of day that
the plant might be a better positioned
to benefit from it and I would say the
second really key challenge that we see
talking a lot is equipment capability or
compatibility so how do you mechanize
farming when you're having to steer
around all these solar panels or all
this electrical infrastructure
so there's a couple different solutions
to this or ways to go about it you know
the main one is using smaller equipment
or hand harvesting plants or plants that
are mainly dealt with by hand
that can let that could limit the
scaling of this solution
um you know certainly one thing that I
I've been asked a lot when I give talks
about this is can we do this with corn
or wheat or soybeans and that seems very
difficult at this time but we can keep
hope alive so that's why you mostly see
these right now you're seeing these uh
proposals more around peppers tomatoes
broccoli kale things that are that are
not harvested with a massive combine and
then finally you know you can maybe
alternate rows of crops with rows of
solar panels which is what I believe
um you know what you see in this bottom
picture here where you kind of have
equipment friendly corridors
around the panel so that one is a little
bit less
um maybe integrated in terms of land use
but it does permit some of these more
recognized approaches
so the Hope really is that arable takes
as the solution could deliver benefits
to a large number of people so when we
talk about the different sort of
stakeholders in this process for Farmers
we want this to be a source of new
revenue streams you essentially have a
new crop electricity
um
a source of drought resistance and water
use efficiency where we're looking at
adapting to potentially increasing
aridity uh in response to climate change
or just needs to limit water due to
aquifer depletion or things like that
pollination of nearby crops you know if
it's a if it's a nearby pollinator solar
habitat you may see crop benefits even
if it's not your land and then finally
on-farm energy production resilience so
ways to generate energy on Farm both uh
May reduce electricity costs for the
farmer but they may also provide a new
source of energy that does not
um that may be harder to interrupt or
may offer some backup power in times in
times of storm or if there was great
issues this is especially important
considering that many rural areas have a
more failure prone electrical grids than
we might experience in the cities
from the solar point of view there's a
potential for more efficient vegetation
management so one of the main
things that solar operators have to do
is maintain all this all the grass or
vegetation around the field so if
they're grazing or people are actively
managing it as a crop land uh you might
be able to get some efficiency there a
potential for as I mentioned earlier
cooling the panels off providing a
favorable microclimate
um water runoff management I mentioned
this earlier but basically vegetation of
various kinds does improve storm water
runoff management and maybe a
favorable strategy for that and then
finally Community acceptance so as we're
thinking through Rural and agricultural
areas increasingly being asked to host
these sites and seeing I think that on a
number of levels in a number of states
concern about solar energy production
displacing agricultural land this may
offer a solution which agricultural land
does not have to be displaced and can be
sort of certain speaking an economic
enhancement
and so you know from the community point
of view we want to think about what they
might be gaining and one is potential
for for the pollinator
um deployment for instance we might see
pollinator habitat or Wildlife
compatibility uh maintaining
agricultural land where that's important
communities which
um I think we see it certainly is
providing jobs and economic
opportunities so this provides a way
perhaps for communities to reap the the
economic benefits of a solar
installation
as well as
um
the agrimal take benefits and then
finally climate mitigation right this is
a this is ideally low or zero carbon
energy production and we may even be
able to see some carbon sequestration uh
depending on the sort of cultivation
practices
so some of the major challenges that I
think we're looking at right now are
system design so you have to combine
designing a solar powered plant with
designing an agricultural system those
are
teams of people who are not necessarily
used to working together
um so we're really working on on
building those teams that have the
expertise we need to do that
the agriculture design is really region
specific and even site-specific you need
to take into account the soil the
climate all of that kind of thing
the
um and so it makes it very difficult to
kind of say well this is the one way to
do it which is maybe a little bit more
less true for solar energy right where
the sun shines is the sun shining you
might need to adapt for the the region
specifics but maybe less site-specific
uh we also see a lot of challenges
scaling this so thus far if you look at
agriculteggs installations the the
dominant form has been kind of small
research scale sites really just proving
this stuff out so really understanding
how we make this work at a scale that
matters for citing right we're talking
about millions and millions of Acres so
how do we make this work at a scale that
can actually affect something
um
and then finally you know there's a lot
of Economics questions here so here we
basically have we have the underlying
land we have the photovoltaic system and
we have agricultural
um crops and assets so there's a lot of
questions about who owns what pieces of
this who leases what pieces of it from
who
how does the money actually flow in the
situation this is kind of key to
figuring out if it's going to attract
farmers and if it's going to actually
benefit farmers and communities and
honestly uh it's something that just
kind of has to be worked out to some
degree but we're already seeing some
people really uh dig into this I would
point to for instance if you'll get the
American Solar grazing Association is a
great professional association
um that does things like publish sample
contracts that grazers can sign with
solar developers and things like that
that really help standardize kind of how
these business Arrangements work
um there's a lot of open questions uh
you know we don't know things about the
long-term impacts of soil energy
infrastructure on soil quality because
it's such a sort of new form of
development at the scale trying to
identify what crops work for this I
think is a major question that's going
to depend on shade tolerance temperature
effects
um all kinds of other things
again the system design question how do
you co-optimize we know how to make we
know how to farm we know how to build
solar panels and we know how to do both
of those kind of optimally and how to
really squeeze every last drop of
production out of either kind but we
don't really know how to build them to
work together
for grazing there's a lot of questions
about how animals will interact with
soil energy equipment um
like I said cheaper more common for this
Purpose with cattle there's there's more
concern
uh I've heard stories from people who've
tried goats and found that goats like to
jump up on panels and play around which
sounds adorable but uh it probably is
not really good for the panels and then
finally again figuring out these
business and contractual Arrangements
because I think a really key open
question
okay so I'm going to take a brief tour
through some of the research that we're
already doing here at Doe
and hopefully this can give you a sense
of kind of where we've been making our
investments and and seeing things we're
excited to see in the near future but
first let me give you a little bit of a
tour through my office just to explain
what it is we do here so we're really
working on advancing and deploying solar
technology to decarbonize the energy
system by 2050 starting with
decarbonizing power by 2035.
that means we're trying to make solar
technology more affordable and
accessible making it support grid
reliability and supporting job growth
manufacturing and circular economies
um and you know we kind of fit uh down
here at the bottom of a long hierarchy
that runs up through uh the under 60 for
energy then the office of Energy
Efficiency and renewable energy and then
finally we stick within a particular
office of Renewable Power so some of our
sister offices are like the wind energy
office the
um hydropower office and the um
well oh the the bioenergy office that's
that's and geothermal
so we have a number of teams in our
office the two that are most involved in
agual takes are strategic analysis and
support so this is kind of our soft cost
team really thinks through these
high-level issues like land use and
Manufacturing competitiveness this is a
team that really works to support early
early stage businesses and kind of works
in the startup space to help people
commercialize new technologies
so we're really working on on a number
of different things whether it's energy
science and field work conducting
analysis
um doing kind of the social science
building communities and also developing
this technology and validating that it
actually works and that spans both kind
of when I when we think of conventional
Technologies which might be sort of
ordinary photovoltaics with
um maybe some spacing between the panels
all the way to new technologies where we
see things like these proposals for
semi-transparent panels or other types
of really Innovative Hardware types
so our Flagship program is a program
called Inspire which is hosted by the
national renewable energy laboratory
along with Argonne National Lab and a
nationwide partnership
buyer is working to build a network of
research sites companies and
universities that are interested in
agricults
and they've been running for a while now
I would say Inspire first started in
actually 2015 and has been doing field
research analytical studies building out
this working group and building a great
website
um where you can where they've been
collecting data and research information
as well as a lot of resources for people
who are interested in getting involved
in this and you can see this is a map of
their project sites and you can see that
they've really done work all across the
country in various types of
um
kind of across the categories I've
talked about so far and that this is
only expanding
so Inspire 3.0 is the newest
um
version of inspire so we kind of have
demonstrated I think that agable takes
is viable but you know the basic idea
does work at research scales and we've
built this really valuable
infrastructure of a network of test
sites and a network of people are
interested in this and the goal is
really to try to map and address the
remaining knowledge gaps and prepare the
sector to start expanding much more
greatly so this product this particular
program is going to run for the next
three years it just started a couple
months ago and is about three and three
quarter million dollars for those three
years just so that this one project
this is about a doubling of their budget
from the last three year cycle which I
think hopefully speaks to our growing
interest in agricults and site
preparation
so some of the things they're doing to
Foster this this community is is to
maintain the the Astro Network which is
their
um group that connects researchers
Advocates and Industry to provide
feedback and and guide the research
program they're going to be funding seed
projects grants of just like a few
thousand dollars each to help students
get started in agroval techs and they're
doing a lot of interagency collaboration
so we know we need to be talking to USDA
certainly the department of the Interior
National Science Foundation and others
really to help build out a federal
complex of people who can support this
type of land use
they'll be providing a lot of work to
sort of help the the research Community
as a whole such as tracking different
sites you know right now we don't have a
centralized database where we can or we
can look up and see what agable tax is
happening in the U.S
um so we kind of have to estimate this
is going to make it much more rigorous
they're going to be performing research
needs assessments and road maps and
conducting economic analysis to
understand the challenges and scaling
these multi-megawatt installations
and then you know they're going to keep
on doing a whole bunch of field work so
um they'll be evaluating agriculture
systems in many different sites and
conditions uh you know over looks like
seven states they'll be looking at
vegetables cotton as well as they're
working with a couple tribal Nations to
look at traditional tribal crops and the
goal is really to find and recommend
what systems work best for this we don't
expect all production to convert into
this on either the solar or the
agricultural side so figuring out sort
of the Venn diagram where this really
works is I think best
uh they'll also be conducting ecosystem
Services analysis really focusing on
pollinator habitat and solar in a number
of states looking at soil science and
Soil Conservation impacts of solar and
starting to look at um bifacial
photovoltaic panels so those are panels
that generate from light that hits the
back of the panel as well as the front
there's a lot of interest in this partly
because plants maybe you know you could
look for plants that are like
particularly reflective for instance
that may provide more of that by facial
advantage
the other group of things that I'd like
to talk about is a bunch of projects
that coming out of a funding opportunity
we launched in fiscal year 20. this is
um a this was a seven million dollar
funding opportunity we have four Awards
in this bucket
um that are all going to last three
years and they're really focusing on
um expanding agricults into new places
into new
um
communities so I'll take you through a
quick tour of some of these these
projects which are in general smaller
than Inspire and and more focused on
particular regions but uh certainly just
as important so the University of
Massachusetts Amherst through their
clean energy extension office is working
on doing yield and soil impacts on a
number of different types of crops
across the state of Massachusetts
looking at economic analysis to
understand what this will do to Farms as
an individual as well as rural economies
and sort of the farm sector as a whole
and what's really interesting about this
is that Massachusetts has as far as I
know I think one of the most aggressive
State programs to encourage agriculture
development in particular
um they have about
um
I want to say it's six cents a kilowatt
hour added to their feed in Terra
Fragger voltaic installation so they're
really providing the economic incentive
for people to make these installations
and there's a lot of interest in
pursuing this
silicon Ranch Corporation in Georgia is
working uh works on regenerative
agriculture and solar plus grazing sites
across the southeast they've really
focused on cheap so far but of course
they're really interested in cattle and
this is a project that's going to focus
on Animal Welfare testing and soil
science monitoring of rotational grazing
systems with cattle in Georgia they're
really focused on tracking the carbon uh
that's stored in the soil to develop new
types of hardware and tracking schedules
that really
facilitate solar plus cattle grazing
University of Illinois Chicago is
focusing on pollinators particularly
large-scale solar facilities so you know
pollinators thus far have been very
focused on
um
have been more focused on the smaller
end and these large-scale facilities 10
megawatt or larger have been a little
bit less clear as to how we can make
pollinators work with potential
additional costs
um what does it take to really set up
these pollinators how does the need for
pollination change when you want to do
you know hundreds of Acres instead of
just a few dozens of acres and so
they're really focusing on how
pollinators can work at very large-scale
solar sites specifically focused in the
Midwest
finally the Agricola Clearinghouse from
the national Center for appropriate
technology so ncat is a
technical assistance group and really
does a lot of great work helping people
with agricultural Technologies and
helping people get started in farming
and they set up this website website and
this site called the Agricola
Clearinghouse which is really focused on
information sharing peer-to-peer
learning relationship building
um for agricultec so if Inspire is
really focused on bringing together the
researchers ncat is really bringing
together practitioners I really
encourage everyone to check out this
website if this is if this talk sounds
interesting to you they're doing a lot
of great work they're producing a lot of
media in the next year and they're doing
site visits to a number of places across
the country but you can register for and
tag along if you'd like a tour of some
interesting interval Tech sites
we also as I mentioned fund uh small
business small businesses and startups
these are much more on the hardware side
so we've done one small business topic
on solar racking and mounting design and
one on solar power iteration for
aquaculture
compounded a number of companies in
these areas
so
um I want to wrap up and make sure I
have time to get to questions but I do
want to flag some things that might be
opportunities for you to engage if this
is something that you or your
organization really want to get involved
in with us in our office so Inspire has
a scoop called Astro that does quarterly
meetings where they present research
where they help develop new research
sites and activities they provide
feedback on Research directions and as
you can see we have a very large number
of collaborators here from AG
environmental to the solar
research and state agencies
um yeah there's we're our team is always
hiring this picture has been taken
several years ago now so it's kind of
funny to see because it's kind of
outdated
um if you know a student who might be
interested in working in a Doe's office
uh particularly post-graduation there's
the Ori science technology policy
Fellowship
um it's not it's very focused on helping
us Implement and design these r d
programs
and this is a great program for
especially new graduates this is how I
first joined the apartment actually uh
please feel free to reach out if you'd
be interested in this
um finally you know if you just want to
keep up with the solar offices work we
have a a newsletter where you can sign
up and get I think it's about a monthly
email about new funding opportunities
Publications and events that we're
hosting
we also host regular webinars to kind of
broadcast some similar information
so I think I can wrap up there and I'd
be happy to take questions now
thank you so much Zach that was
fantastic overview and and super
um informative
um
I am going to start with rosemary these
questions I am a beekeeper the idea that
pollinator habitat can exist under solar
panels is not feasible none of the sites
that we have seen so far in New York
install these habitats the areas have to
be mowed and maintained to access the
panels how are you seeing this happening
it sounded great but it's not happening
unless a completely different location
on the site and most of women's dollars
want to use the entire site for solar
production thank you
I think that um
I think that we're seeing
um I'm not aware of the status in New
York so I'm a little bit uh unclear I
think we have uh
some opportunities to to work with this
as we go through the UIC project which
is really focusing on these large-scale
sites you're right that many operators
want to devote um the entire site to
um solar production I think at the state
level we're starting to see more States
and I again I don't know about New York
specifically
um focusing on production uh or focusing
on ways to encourage pulmonary habitat
or compatibility
um I I know there's at least one company
out there that's selling honey that they
at least claim was his entirely
um grown with pollinator habitat on
solar sites so I'd be happy to try to
connect you with that I am
I think that uh this is still very early
days yet so I don't think it's it's
happening at Large Scale or even at most
solar sites this is more something we're
still trying to enable
so David K asks
um about 60 of U.S Farmland is owner
operated according to the 2017 census of
agriculture
um and it has been fairly stable over
longest periods of time this raises
issues of one
um split incentives for agricults where
the land is not owned by the farmer and
two changing value of the land that
increases the incentive for non-farmers
to own land currently in farms any work
on these questions going on
yeah I think so for one I think that's
that's
for split incentives I think that's
definitely a major question I think that
that is one of those things where
um it may be that perhaps it only works
for owner-operated Farmland um but I
think this really is up to somewhat up
to the industry to discover what
commercial practices might actually work
here
um and I think that that's going to be a
difficult uh question I mean we see the
same thing for instance in uh
renter you know rented homes as well
there's this incentive program
um so I don't think there's an easy
answer to that question I think it's
something that uh will kind of depend on
what economic opportunities actually
emerge and where those benefits actually
fall I think the uh work I've seen so
you know certainly grazing and in some
similar
for instance okay so in pollinators it's
less about finding a dedicated farmer
and grazing we're seeing more of the
service model emerge uh for croplands I
think it uh it depends I I think um we
haven't really seen what the commercial
models look like for that yet so it's a
little bit difficult to answer in terms
of changing value of land I think we
know very little about that to be honest
I we don't know enough about how this
type of development impacts land values
in the long term because too much of it
is too new
I'm gonna follow up with a personal
question so what do you think about
activating this idle or marginal or
underutilized land that Peter was
talking about at the beginning which may
not be associated with Farmers like how
how is the national perspective looking
at engaging non-farmers in
um in activating these shrug scrub or
other land areas
yeah I think it's um it's an interesting
question I mean one thing that's a
little bit tough is that I think the
land use discussion from from the land
use side is sometimes not the one that
uh
so if you talk to Developers for
instance about how they find and try to
identify land is
um
you know the the primary driver of that
is often transmission access so where is
their transmission where is their
transmission capacity where can I plug
into the grid and that can kind of
that kind of puts us something on a back
foot because we're being reactive to
that need
um and so we're really trying to find
the um
we're really trying to figure out what
the uh
trying to figure out how we can find
lands that might be useful for solar
that also sort of meet these commercial
goals as well as maybe meeting other
land use coals so this is part of what I
I mentioned that there's been some
efforts I think uh to pre-identify land
that might be useful for solar
um or to kind of you know
you can imagine sort of stoplight
systems where we say okay don't develop
here to develop here try not to develop
here things like this there's a lot of
concerns I think with this in part
because
um you need really good data and it's
very hard to say well are you really
taking into account everything that you
need to know to do that kind of thing
um to to really be able to say for
certain the development wheel or won't
work in a certain place and then I think
the final thing that you might think
about is we are seeing some states I
think sort of try to provide incentives
or directions on where so where they'd
like to see Solar Development so that's
I mentioned Massachusetts has this feed
and tariff program for agricultural land
it actually is or not for our cultural
land but for dual use
agricults it also deals with a lot of
other stuff as well I would say so for
instance
um
uh
uh landfills I know are one they
encourage Solar Development on former
landfills so these land cap landfills
often the ground is not really stable
enough to build housing or things like
that on it but it can be used for for
panels
um so we're we're working on trying to
understand better what that um
what kinds of policy impacts or what
kinds of policy Landscapes influence
those land use choices
I'm going to follow up quickly with one
more because we've got some more time uh
what is the national perspective on if
we're moving towards electrification how
can we think about the next generation
of grid development to facilitate both
energy security for Citizens but then
also
um this this Initiative for
developing the renewable portfolio
yeah it's a good question I mean I think
you sort of have two different
um
two different kind of perspectives on
this I mean one is about large-scale
transmission lines just trying to
balance whole regions and and kind of
between states and that's certainly one
need you see to make these kind of
renewable
um
uh grants feasible it gets much easier
if you can move power very easily across
the country and then kind of on the
local level you also see a need to adapt
to new higher loads especially I mean
the two things that people talk about
the most are a
um electric vehicles and the need to be
able to handle the high loads that might
come with charging up if you need to
charge a vehicle quickly and then the
other is heat pumps especially questions
about like well you know just Before
Sunrise before the solar comes on quite
cold if you are have an electrified
system you might suddenly see a really
clear need for more generation there and
that's um
a great challenge as well I would say is
making sure that everyone can actually
access that electricity
so Brian Aldrich asks one hopefully
minor but practical issue to address is
we control under and around the
immediate perimeter of the panels there
are time and material costs required for
this task hopefully the revenue stream
will cover these costs I'm curious to
hear how farmers are handling this got
any stories
yeah
um I don't know if I have any particular
stories I will say that
um you know the thing is for we control
is the solar solar fields are always
going to have to deal with weed control
right like the outside of Agriculture
you're having to spray or mow this whole
field and so if there is still some weed
control left after you know there's
there some of it is devoted to cropping
then I think that there's there's
kind of a question of what Baseline are
you measuring it from and so it can be
it can maybe be looked at as a fraction
of the cost that you would have spent on
weed control perhaps otherwise
um I don't know about this particular
practice people are using for this but
yeah
Jen Blair asks how do solar panels
impact the soil there must be compaction
erosion and the need to build an access
road for maintenance over 20 plus year
period how does this impact the land
from ever returning to growing crops
yeah I mean that is a really great
question I think that's certainly one
thing that we're still
trying to understand I mean I think that
the the truth of the matter is it hasn't
been studied as much as maybe it needs
to be
um
some points on on solar compaction I
will say that this has been addressed
somewhat by people who are working in
the Brownfield sector where often there
might be soil that is for contamination
purposes you really don't want to
disturb it too much and I've seen that
there have been some really use there
have been some really clear
guidelines uh developed in that sector
for avoiding um compact uh sorry erosion
and runoff in those cases
um looking into things like just
limiting uh weight and things like that
so in the landfill and Brownfield sector
you see people dealing with that
um
in terms of in the long term I think the
thing is that's important to understand
this is a really wide array of
um solar practices that can be used
during land uh development and part of
the question is also what practices are
people actually using and
what are the addition what would be the
additional cost of adopting you know
less impactful or more soil conserving
practices and part of that I think it
can hopefully be assisted by saying hey
we do want to maintain this as an
agricultural land either now or in the
future
um the other because one thing we have
talked a little bit about is whether or
not a solar uh so the lifetime solar
plant is about 30 years so one question
is you know can this be something that
is used you know temporarily and then we
say after 30 years we're going to pull
this out and do and and uh resume
cultivation on this land
um maybe after building some soil for
that for those decades um and I think
that also remains to be seen we're still
working on it
uh Roberta Nelson says relatedly to
Jan's question I'm curious what is known
about the impact of large-scale PV on
local Water Resources such as whether
water is needed to clean the panels how
water drains off the panels and any
impacts to Water Resources based on the
digging Drilling in into the pools are
these questions that have been answered
and researched or is it ongoing yeah so
we have research on on some of these so
uh for cleaning the panels I think the
answer is yes but not frequently so
there is panel cleaning but it's not
done very frequently it might not be
done at all actually in states with
higher rainfall so you know it's but it
is something that is often done in sort
of dustier more arid climates
um
you know one advantage that there's
there's no need to use drinking water
quality water for that and there's I
have seen some uh suggestions to use
sort of gray water or things like that
um I also know that I've also seen
um proposals to recycle or
um
otherwise gather collect that water and
perhaps use it for either watering in an
agriculture
um setting so you know clean the panels
and then irrigate with that water
um or potentially
um
just collect it for some other purpose
for water draining all the panels This
is a really interesting question uh from
a storm water management perspective we
do have a project called PV smart at
nrel
um which is uh I don't know what the
smart stands for but it stands for storm
water management something or other so
if you if you look that up uh I really
recommend it they've been doing a lot of
work uh especially looking at like local
zoning officials and talking to
environmental Regulators state level to
try to understand a what are the impacts
of solar on stormwater runoff do you do
potentially see like increased erosion
at the drip edge of the panel but maybe
there's you know there are ways
potentially to alleviate that or to work
against that or to try to counteract
that
um
finally for impacts to Water Resources
based on digging slash Drilling in the
poles
um I'm not really aware of that I mean I
don't think that they're usually deep
enough to to impact groundwater with
that but I'm I'm not sure I I'm not
aware of any research in that area
David bem asks any research or insights
on potential of battery storage sites
that would not be located near
transmission lines and where the
generated power would be temporarily
stored until it is dispersed to users
from the sewer generation site
yeah so that's like kind of an off-grid
or um maybe called micro grid solution I
mean I think it's certainly something
very interesting those Solutions tend to
be
well it's not to say like so if you look
at the microgrid stuff often in
isolation say wow that's that's so
expensive but because you have to build
all this extra storage and all this kind
of management
um and kind of electrical infrastructure
on the other hand if you're
way out there and you're gonna have to
build a transmission line miles and
miles it can look a lot it can look a
lot better so I think some of that is is
uh certainly difficult and as storage
costs decline will probably come into
perspective for communities I think the
other thing is if you're going to do
that it really one of the major
questions is what what size of load are
you hoping to serve I mean is that are
you open a service a town that's all
that's that's very far or has limited
transmission access are you just trying
to service that one farming facility and
depending on that is really going to
drive a lot of the questions of how you
would make that work
okay your last question Zach
uh thanks for this very clear and
helpful presentation can you speak a bit
to the embodied carbon of solar panels
materials used and lifespan
yeah
um it's great it's a very good question
I think it's always important to keep
this in mind I I think uh as we talk
about moving to like low or or zero
carbon sources we even remember this so
um I don't know offhand this these
embodied carbon numbers I do know that
from what I've been told most of the
carbon that's actually in solar well
there's a couple of sources one of it is
steel like you have all this racking and
stuff so some of it is about
decarbonizing steel production which we
need to do along the way and some and
some of it is about
um the electricity that's used in the
production process so what's good about
those is those are both
um kind of decarbonization problems that
people are are kind of focused on
separately
um and if we were if we had a
decarbonized Electric System and if we
had if we figure out how to build make
steel out of hydrogen or or electrical
reduction or whatever
um we would probably be able to produce
solar panels you know in a very low
carbon impact kind of way
um of course that's not the state we're
in now so that is something to mind I I
mean I certainly think that it Compares
there's there's no comparison with um
any of the fossil fuel sources
generation or anything like that it's
it's
um still a fairly low embodied carbon
um in terms of lifespan I think that
currently you know we I think use
usually 30-year lifespans as a standard
estimate I will say that a major
research Focus for us at this time is
trying to extend that
um to 40 or 50-year lifespans and the
purpose for that is really to say hey if
you're gonna you know the the a solar
panel or a solar farm has the
interesting kind of set up that it's all
investment right there's no fuel costs
the operational maintenance costs are
usually pretty low
um but there's this huge Capital cost up
front and so if you can make it last
longer than as an asset it sort of the
longer it lasts the more it pays off and
the more that um initial Capital cost
really pays pays for itself so there's
there's a there's an effort right now to
really improve the durability but um
I think 30 years is currently kind of
where we at now and 30 years might be
this is when it's economical to replace
the panels with newer more efficient
panels right it might not be you know
that doesn't mean that they're they're
they're
um necessarily garbage at that point
thank you so much Zach it was a
fantastic presentation
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu